all right so you need an idea for this
yes all right I do because we're less
than 24 hours what it's supposed to go
like Danny you're in luck you've come to
the right place all right I am bursting
with ideas okay first idea yeah top five
reasons show night is the greatest game
ever made number one each other's yeah
number two nights and so on you'll fill
in the gaps not an idea man as well I
feel like it needs to be all right so
when we're picking something for the
point it's like gaming zeitgeist games
have come out this week Sheldon like you
met last week two hours ago right so now
there's a lot cultural zeitgeist all
right potato salad Kickstarter and is
all over the news
all right what how can you tap into that
game top five games about potato salad
maybe one who gave myself a bitter side
of this grand theft auto 5 is it
actually maybe I'll be honest I don't
know no try again ok what else is
happening in the world the International
four okay yeah okay it's hot five Donal
teen characters ready but here's a video
about the International by people who
aren't the International and don't know
all that much about the World Cup
come on yeah we did that's alright okay
so here it is alright the best games
made by Germans and the best games made
by Argentinians
now one game made by an Argentinian
uh-huh the German was easy
yeah I think like we've got Crytek
there's all kinds of adventure games and
both instant version of Wolfenstein did
that don't have they did the original
Wolfenstein
see isn't a zero-sum Stein or a
two-story visions just world war 2
what about Brazil there's something like
10 gently associated with Brazil yeah
I'm at Max Payne 3 ok Brazil that was a
great game it was a great game
yeah hey guys remember Max Payne 3 the
point that week 1 games I hope you read
easy to do because we wouldn't have to
pick music because we could just pull
this from the soundtrack which was done
by health but yeah I gotcha it's like
really good and it's also low and [__]
so it'll just you know I don't have to
worry about descriptive words oh here
you know right Max Payne shaped heads
you said it looks like power he does so
you've already got the American audience
yeah which is always a risk when you're
doing anything related to international
events oh yeah supper you know football
football do you know how much [__] I got
for maiming have soccer last week it was
part of the joke for two weeks ago I
guess weeks just meld together yeah what
else of a Brazil what about the Zeebo
those people good what about gazebos the
Zeebo the CEO the Zeebo Brazil's of
Brazil exclusive console yeah people
don't realize that the Zeebo was ahead
of its time
yeah it was a 3G enabled console did we
have a Zeebo here does anyone have a
seed everybody had a Zeebo it's Peter
Brown Peter dooms ahead of GameSpot
packed New York
what is it what does it do it's
she enables console that was made in
Brazil because like Playstations and
Xbox is cost like five grand because of
the way they do tax for technology top
five reasons the Zeebo is the greatest
micro console available only in Brazil
of all time number one it had 3G number
two ahead of 584 megahertz processor ok
we close the door on shovelknight a
little too soon this game is great it's
got frogs who are also made of
electricity so that's a universal appeal
right there could we do an episode of
the point about all the weird portraits
of tammana bhatia yes this one right
there over there there's more over there
this is a picture of Tom and his his
great-great-grandfather Tom topper hem
Tom shave your head and grow beard and
then we can do some so we can jump from
you Brazil to Max Payne and then Brazil
sure for 20 seconds of footage on the
point I'll do anything
great all right Andy got ourselves a
show